the girag an experience my daughter
loves Bible stories really I'm I'm an
atheist
GJ once upon a time before you tell them
oh I know she knows their stories okay
yeah we call him the big invisible guy
and you go old-school Old Testament or
do you know we do the whole thing oh
yeah I'm told to the story of you know
did the guy who's gonna kill his son
because the big invincible guy I say man
and I scream like bake him in a pie with
whipped cream because you know it's a
terrific I don't have a knife to the
throat I mean she's she was four but she
loves the big 'visible guy story sir she
loves the Noah one she loves to Adam and
Eve one with the snake and the Apple
that's all I mean these stories that
they've stood the test of time there's
really some of the best stories around
who was guy killed his son was Cain and
Abel no no Cain and Abel were the son of
Adam and Eve they were brothers yeah and
they killed each other right said Isaac
and Abraham I think I know Isaac and not
you know okay do we have a webcam hey
but yeah Abraham is gonna kill the son
right yeah so thank God who's asking him
to kill a son for him yeah that you know
as a love test yeah just because you
know that's how you know yeah if someone
really loves you like you know this is
why you know you give this you give this
to your wife you know like I would I
would murder our offspring for you and
that's the whole Marquardt that really
helps your wife understand how much you
love her I'm just or an ex-boyfriend if
you're a marine expert I would find that
way to export from the beat you up I'll
murder him and sell you I love you but
and I'm trying to tell the stories in a
neutral way right like it's I again I
write my opinions on all these stories
and all that but she really likes the
stories and she's a huge fan of Lucifer
whoa
I mean Lucifer is the guy he is like her
superhero you know like he is her Mighty
Morphin Power Rangers she thinks he is
just the coolest because he's always
standing up to big invisible guy right
and right because for her prayer is you
know everyone standing around say oh you
are the best oh you're the best
oh you're the greatest I love you so
much oh you're the best you know and so
you know Lucifer gets kind of tired of
that and leads the rebellion and all
that because you know I said you know
just keep saying it she's on getting
tired of it's like but not gonna keep
saying it because it's an eternity of
saying that to the guy right and she's
like oh man I'm really tired I want to
sit down it's like now you know how
Lucifer fucking keeps them out of it
anyway so she's got this great she's
this great song yeah which goes
basically Lucifer was Ron Luce ofoh was
right you know and Wow
songs and I'm just waiting because you
know in Canada there's some
homeschooling which is kind of all our
in schooling what we were doing but a
lot of them are Christians right so we
can at some point be around a bunch of
Christian kids she's gonna break into
this song and I'm looking forward to
that moment of trying to explain that
maybe she's referring to a Beatles song
I don't know I completely bail on her at
that point I don't know what she gets it
well the real issue is you're gonna have
to mingle with those Christian parents
the real issue when you have children
besides raising the children which is of
course the primary one teaching them and
everything is dealing with these other
parents and seeing it's it's really
weird when I see people with their kids
you know see how little they interact
with their kids see how like not
appreciative they are of their kids how
they're always distracted or bring of
cellphones around the playground yeah
you know like you throw your cell phone
go play go into stupid McDonald's tubes
and go play with your kids I know a
woman who's a psychologist and she picks
up her kid and she's on her phone while
she's picking the kid up the kids trying
to talk to her about schooling uh-huh
uh-huh uh-huh
and she's texting it's it's you know I
mean you just the kid was gone for five
hours when you picking them up you're
texting yeah it's it's so it's so
attractive to us though so easy to do
it's so easy to ignore we get so used to
you know the kid being around and we get
so used to her own free time that oh my
daughter is really good at that
sorry to drive it she's great because
you know like I'm trying to teach her
eye contact right because you know when
she's a kid you know I don't know if
they can't focus when they look at you
but they tell stories like they're just
watching the biggest disco light show on
the planet and you're just like some
leaf or something right and so I tried
to remind her you know eye contact when
we're talking that kind of stuff right
so the other day of course and I you
know I try Oh Joe I try you know and I
you know but every now and then like I
get donations my whole show is just
donations right no ads or anything and
so if you know when a donation comes in
it's like whoo kibble you know like I'm
like the rat with the pellet you know
okay but what did they get and I got
this little catching noise that comes in
because I'm for anyway so you know the
kitchen noise come in my daughter was
telling me something really important
for her and all that and and yeah she's
great she's like four she's like Daddy
iContact like you're absolutely right
I'm so sorry how rude that was of me I
apologize that's hilarious
yeah it's fascinating to watch their
little brains develop isn't it watch the
way they interact with each other
see the world and realize like that this
is how a person is shaped and this is
the number one problem that we have as a
race is that we don't respect this
process and that we also don't respect
this process and strangers especially
people that we know are fucked people in
bad neighborhoods people in bad
circumstances people in abusive families
we know they're fucked and we don't we
don't do anything to stop it
one thing that I keep harping on is that
if we have a resource whether it's oil
or gold being we protect that resource
and you know we we set up laws and we
attach a value to it
but our number one resource for sure is
human beings we have created all that
you see whether it's laptops or
buildings or cars
that's all from a human being the best
way to ensure that that continues to go
on is to have less losers in the world
the best way to have less losers is help
out kids educate kids get on the ball
with them very early and do something as
a society protect them primary before we
go into Wars before we go into all this
stupid shit that we do spying on
people's fucking emails and looking into
their cell phone record before you do
any of that how about you protect kids
first that should be of primary
importance and it should be like one of
those things where your kid you know
wants to go out and play if you done
your homework you haven't done your
homework you can't play it's that
fucking simple you can't have your wars
unless you fix the kids okay I'm there
they're so smart and I you know I was
human I've had a whole bunch of experts
on my show which is you talk about the
native intelligence of kids like kids
can start doing mathematical reasoning
at seven or eight months of age they can
start do using empathy at 14 months my
daughter at the age of four we started
playing a game called subjective versus
objective you know like is this
something subjective like I like ice
cream or is this something objective
like ice cream is made from milk and you
know we pointed stuff as a subject to
her objective you know I like jazz
subjective or objective and she's like
bang rattling them off the other day she
was saying to me dad you know we've
talked a lot she's always asked me about
the show in fact I should have been
taking notes because she's asked me all
about you what's gonna be the topic and
I said you know what I have no idea I
know it's gonna be interesting to chat
with you no idea what we're going to
talk about
and conversation yeah yeah she's asked
all about you know where you're from and
what you do and she's fascinated by
mixed martial arts and all that kind of
stuff and and so she's gonna ask me also
be and I do some shows on economics and
so we talked a little bit about that you
know fiat money and all that I grab
stuff out for her that she gets it
really gone through the whole history of
the Second World War the other thing she
says you know my daddy I think I've
decided what I want to do I think when I
get bigger I I think I just like to work
I think I want to be the government I'd
love to be the government because I just
I want to type whatever I wanted to my
bank account and I was just like wow you
just nailed the Federal Reserve like
right there in a night yeah whatever I
want into my bank account bank over your
old logic but perfect yeah it is what it
is they can print their own money yeah
it's beautiful great system yeah no one
I come out of the sort of libertarian
world right so I mean I'm an anarchist
but I come out of the libertarian world
and libertarians very much as we talked
about law non-aggression principle and
so on and I've been fighting this this
battle in the libertarian world and in
other worlds as well around you know
things to me as basic as spanking right
oh yeah yeah I wasn't sure we touched on
this we did with more on the yen about
this just throw a few stats for the
audience who hasn't seen it before more
than 90% of parents of toddlers say they
spank their child toddlers sixty sixty
one percent of moms three to five year
olds have spanked their child in the
past week boys spanked a lot more than
girls boys are also diagnosed with ADHD
which is one of the symptoms of spanking
a lot more than girls spanking can
continue into the adolescent years
thirty to forty percent of people in
junior high kids in junior high still
being spanked moms do spank children a
lot more than fathers do even
controlling for time spent with kids and
all of that kind of stuff
economic status doesn't have a huge
amount to do with spanking but culture
death so african-americans do do a lot
more corporal punishment religious
conservatives fundamentalist do a lot
more corporal punishment and so on and
this to me is is such a fundamental
thing I'm very much for a philosophy
that you can do philosophy that you can
act on values that you can do yeah I
don't like the Federal Reserve I think
central banking is a Monstress cancer in
the eyeball of society but I can't
really do much about it other than rant
and rave about it but we can't what we
can do is
now do some basics like stop hitting
kids you know that to me is a very
fundamental thing and in the libertarian
community that's a challenge lot a lot
of religious conservatives in the
libertarian community as you know like
on the on the right around Republicans
that tend to be more religious people on
the left the secularists less religious
people but more socialist and so on and
it is really tough you know to just get
that basic thing across we tell kids not
to hit each other and we hit kids we've
all I don't know if you out that you see
bad parenting sometimes when you read
and you act you actually and I'll
usually say something to the parents
because I don't want my my a I think
it's rightly to do I don't want my
daughter to see me be all about the
ethics and then not talk to people doing
something wrong but you can see parents
hit kids saying don't hit your sister
mm-hmm and that the fact that they can
do that without their heads exploding
from this wormhole contradiction of
pretzel logic is just astounding but it
is something we still have a long way to
go in I think we're kind of slowly
getting there but we have a long way to
go and just let's not hit kids yeah I
think how much of the world would change
if we didn't do that would I think we
would be virtually unrecognizable as a
culture I couldn't agree more you know I
read this our article recently on my
message board I don't have it in front
of me so I apologize to whoever posted
it but it's about a man who got stuck in
the financial system of divorce and it
was from his perspective he committed
suicide lit himself on fire I started
reading his perspective and they came to
his house and you know he had his
initial issue because he slapped his
daughter in the mouth so hard that her
mouth was bleeding and he did it because
she was licking his hand
she kept licking his hand so he slapped
her in the mouth til her mouth was me
and then everything I I stopped reading
right there I'm like I don't want to
know this guy and I don't I'm sad that
he was so fucked up that he committed
suicide but if I saw a guy slap his
daughter in the face because she you
know was licking his hand I would have
to really suppress my urge to strangle
him yeah I mean that's violence that's
violence to someone who cannot defend
themselves and can't leave not only it
used to be there not only that it's it's
fundamentally the most fucked up kind of
violence because you're doing it to a
developing human being who you allegedly
love you're teaching them that violence
is a part of life by the people that
they respect the most and that it can be
done to you at
time when you don't agree with whatever
fucking guidelines and rules they've set
up like licking your hand my daughter
was licking my head I'd be laughing my
ass off I would think it's so funny the
idea that I'd smack her in the mouth is
just fucking insane
but people they fall into this pattern
and they don't know don't realize that
violence is violence just because you're
not going to hurt the kid that bad
you're just gonna spank them you think
it's no big deal fuck yeah it's a big
deal yeah because that kid it's a
horrific situation you're doing
something they can't control your
holding their arm you're moving their
body and then this big hand comes and
slaps their ass and they feel pain and
they feel confused cuz you've acted out
against them you've not only acted out
against them you've done it aggressively
yelling and slapping and like it's a
terrible it's terrible precedent to set
a terrible idea to plant in a child's
mind and it's unnecessary it's just not
necessary for you to tell me that you
can't sit down and reason with your
child and do it with love and the yeah
they're gonna freak out and fucking
flail sometimes they get mad and yell
and that's cuz they're a fucking child
you piece of shit
you don't smack them you know you don't
smack em George are you hitting your
friends it's like hitting your friend
on't hit anybody man well and and in
particular you know the moral
concentration of like black-hearted
nastiness you know you hit your wife she
got to date you she got to you know you
had an engagement she you know she chose
you and you chose her but if you hit
your wife she at least had to get to
test-drive you shit you know and then
she can leave at any time she's an adult
she's got shelters she's got whatever
people will help her hope but kids they
didn't choose you as parents Akal you
know and they can't leave and and they
have no options and I say this to my
daughter you know I say umm I say I know
you're not here by choice you know you
didn't choose me is it I choose to have
kids and you didn't choose me as a dad
the way I have to parent is I want to
parent like if my daughter did have a
choice of any dad in the world that she
would choose me like and so I imagine
ice cream cookies all day long
absolutely and and I reduce and and and
what about feedback you know and I go to
my local pizza joint half the time have
to fill out why don't they give me this
comment card to fill out you know how
did you like the pizza you know was
really good for you was it bad for you
yeah they want to know they want to have
a good pizza
and how many times the parents do that
with their kids say how am i doing you
know how sim your experience of my
parenting you know what's more important
can slice of pizza or your relationship
with your offspring you know ask them
how you're doing how could today have
been better what did I do that you liked
what did I do that you didn't like and
all that get that kind of feedback I
don't it's just weird that we don't even
think of doing that I think your
perspective is very unique in the fact
that you are stay-at-home dad you do
have the resources to be able to do that
it's it's really hard for a lot of
people that's what you were talking
about before that number is pretty crazy
the twenty minutes a week I didn't know
that it was that low but honestly not
shocked I don't have a regular life but
I've dabbled in regular life you know
I've had like jobs that take me away for
a long period of time during the day and
I could only imagine what kind of energy
you have to devote to a kid if the
mother both mother and the father both
leave the house all day long work an
eight-hour day and then come home how
much is left there's not even much time
the kid's gonna be a week yeah how much
energy do you have left how much focus
are you putting on that kid during the
day and and we have this get a couple
more stats we have this idea that the
moms have to be there and the dads can
be there but a study conducted by dr.
Kyle Pruitt found that infants between 7
and 30 months respond more favorably to
being picked up by their fathers he also
found a fathers parenting style is
beneficial for a child's physical
cognitive and emotional and behavioral
development a mother's tend to reassure
toddlers when they become frustrated
while fathers encouraged them to manage
their frustration my daughters like this
sighs she's learning to do all these
things and most of her friends were
older because you know were nothing like
youngest parents on the block and so a
lot of her friends can do stuff better
than she can she gets frustrated me
helping her talk it through that
frustration and reminding her that I
didn't know how to do this stuff and you
know she's trying to do racquet sports
and I remember take me years to become
good at racquet sports so so that's
important for for kids as well I mean
it's really important to remember you
know that the mom and the kid they used
to be the same freakin person you know
like that she grew her they like the
it's like my arm you know it's not like
a separate thing where's dad still have
a little bit more objectivity around
that longer term study that this guy did
to prove that her father's active
involvement with his kids from birth to
adolescence promotes greater emotional
balance stronger curiosity a stronger
sense of self assurance
additional studies during the first five
years of a child's life the father's
role is more influential than the
mothers in how the child learns to
manage his or her body navigate social
social circumstances in play
and the last one is this the 1996 study
that I was referring to before by McGill
University the single most important
childhood factor in developing empathy
his paternal involvement in childcare
the study further concluded that
children who spend time alone bonding
with their children more than twice per
week brought up the most compassionate
adults so how do they measure that has
our quantifiable it seems like a weird
all those statistics seem very odd it's
like how do you know what caused a
person to have more empathy how do you
know what caused a person to be able to
move better and I mean how do you how do
well what they prove that again it's
sort of a many-to-many relationship so
they they ask the fathers you know how
often were you involved and maybe they
even measure them if it's sort of a live
study and then they measure the
compassion and then they measure a whole
bunch of other things and if the other
things don't change the compassion
measure but then the parental
involvement is what moves the needle
then they assume that that's close to
causal but isn't the issue also the
parental involvement like say if a
father is involved a lot and the kid's
life he's also probably likely involved
in the relationship with the wife and
maybe the wife would be more happy the
father and the wife would be more happy
and because of that they would both be
better parents it could you know it
might not just be that the impact of
having a man around does all these
things and creates an empathy it might
be the impact of having a successful
family as well right right now and that
certainly is true and again I didn't run
the studies I assume that they've tried
like whenever you question this all we
tried to tease it out this way or that
way they they do try to find that answer
but I do think that compassion again you
know I mean your marriage you've got
you've got kids floating around and all
that and I'm floating but they're about
that they were floating at one point and
then they came out through the magic
chamber but I think you know I mean my
wife skills as a parent are fantastic
and but but there are some differences
between us you know and I don't know
whether it's biological or whether it's
just the way we're raised or whatever
but you know I encourage more
risk-taking I'm encouraged you know if
you fall off the horse get back up on
again kind of stuff and I think that's
just a kind of a natural kind of
difference and
I'm also more encouraging of you know my
daughters like crazy friendly I keep
thinking she's gonna go up to someone
sometimes an unfriendly world like a
cheese up to a grater you know it just
kinda get shredded because you know we
go places and she just goes up to kids
and says hi would you like to be friends
and that's cool Oh fantastic
that's a dealer you know the world of
the little you know oh I love it
wouldn't everybody was on ecstasy that's
how we would interact with each other
[Music]
you